Welcome back to PJ Chain Design. This is
PJ. Today I would like to show you how
to step by step design this lucky leaf
pendant with the B setting arrange
correctly on it. Are you ready? Let's
get started.
[Music]
Let's take a look on the structure of
this pendant. They all four pendant are
the same. Uh four leaf are the same. So
they're coming into the angle with the
stone arrange on it. So we just need to
create one and polar array. Now the key
is when you have them all polar array
that all the stone is going to jam in
together. So we wanted those two going a
little bit higher and then uh if it is
uh cutting into the stone we're going to
use the prong to replace it. Okay. So
that's starting from the scratch. So,
we're going to come into a front view
and you can trace over a real image if
you want to or you can just uh play
with, you know, your instinct for
whatever it it should look like. And so,
I'm going to do something like this,
right? And it's always nice to trace
something because it's maybe the shape
will get more close, but for this
demonstration, I'm going to leave it
like that. Okay, so that's one. Um, and
then I'm going to mirror to the other
side and to get this like a horshaped
looking things. First things we wanted
to check, let me group them together.
And I wanted to use the polar array and
snapping into the zero. And I need to
have four of them. And make sure I want
to record a history on the bottom for
360 degree. All right. So, this one
doesn't look too bad. Um, but if this
one is where the stone is going to run,
we also need to make sure they are a
little bit away from each other. So, we
have the stone sitting in there. For
example, I'm this is going to represent
the stone and my stone is going to be
like a 1 mm. So, will be something like
that, right? So, in that case, I might
need to moving those in a little bit. So
you're thinking about you have 1 mm
stone going to run all the way here and
you're also going to run all the way
here. So you don't want them to be like
two jamming into each other. Okay. Once
you got that uh secure, we can delete
the rest. Just want to use as a
reference. And we want to uh explode it
this guy one more time. Um actually I
didn't join. So I just need to ungroup
it. Uh I'm going to delete half of them
and come back to here.
And coming into my front view or
actually the top view. I actually want
to rotate it the angle a little bit. Uh
that will make it more interesting. So
I'm going to simply just rotate like
this. All right. So this is where my
stone is going to run from here to
there. And I also wanted to creating the
surface for the stone to sit on. So I
wanted to uh using the command for
offset curve and I want to offset on
both side uh each side is 6 mm so that
it's creating 1.2 mm in order for me to
put 1 mm stone right in the middle.
Okay. Now the surface has to pass the
middle point as you can see it's not on
you know on one end for both of the uh
curve that we have here. So I'm simply
just going to make it a little bit
longer. So I got to coming into the
curve. You have extended curve and we
can just pick up this end. Hit enter.
And then we just want them to be a bit
longer. The same thing right here. I'm
going to pick it right here. Going to
make it slightly longer. Right. So that
can I'm going to snapping into the zero
and draw a straight line. And so that
way we can have this line to trim off
anything is stick it out. So when we
mirror there will be a good transition
there. Okay. Uh I'm going to delete this
line. That's just for our cutting tool.
And then we can creating this surface.
Let's take a look on the perspective.
Right. It's tilted in the angle like the
way that we like. So I'm going to draw a
straight line from this point to this
point. and draw another straight line
from this point to this point. All
right. So to creating the surface, we
wanted to have the sweep to rail. You
got rail one, you got rail two,
cross-section here and here. And then
you get this one right there. It's
pretty good surface right there. Doesn't
have any weird twist. Uh so we don't
have to adjust anything. All right. Now
to making the stone flow really well, we
wanted to bring in the first stone. And
you can download the stone at the
description below. That way you have a
stone to use for this demonstration. And
I'm going to move my stone in my front
view. I'm going to move my stone and
close the end to the that end point
right there. Okay. I also want to come
into the top view and tilted my stone
follow exactly angle that I have over
there for my curve. Maybe a little bit
more in the angle of this. Okay. And
then I'm also want to come into my right
view and see if it is in the right
place. All right. So, we can give it a
try and see how the things flow. Let's
go ahead to use the transform. And we
have the array along curve. And this is
the object we're going to array. And
this is the curve we're going to have.
Right? And notice that it's only have
two of them. So I'm going to making a
lot more maybe 15 of them. And take a
look on the distance in between. Ideally
we want a distance to be 0.1 mm. So this
apparent is is a little bit too loose.
But let's go ahead to try to try 16 and
see if it's touching. If it's not
touching it's close to the 0.1 mm and
that's what we are looking for. All
right. I also want to make sure that as
you can see I want to record a history
and and click okay. This one is too far
away from the surface. So I'm just going
to move it down. So the girdle of the
stone is actually on the surface. It's
not flying out there. All right. So if
that is working for you, we will need to
work on the prong. So basically for the
prong I would like to draw a straight
line and follow the direction of this
guy as well. Uh you can tilt it later if
you that work for you better. And for
this one I simply just want to pipe it.
We want to pipe it for like a 6 mm. So
it the radius for.3. And let's take a
look if this is too fat or not enough or
something like that. Let's moving this
to there. It look like it's too fat for
one millimeter. So, in fact, I need to
get it slightly smaller. I wanted to
have like 0.25
and see if that work better. And let's
go ahead to bring this one to the right
location and bring it up at the front
view. And we want to to move it here.
All right. That will make sure if that
is the right place. Uh if it is the
right place, we want to move it down to
somewhere in between here and take a
look if that is the right place. Look
like it's a little bit sink too much. So
I'm going to coming into this view and
move it out a little bit. All right. So
if those two and those two are quite
important if those two work correctly,
we are going to pick up those two and we
are going to use exactly the same
command for array along curve. And we
want to pick up the curve and then so
they will follow hopefully it's correct
there. All right. And once you are done
you want to come in and check on all the
prong uh in detail and see which one
need adjustment. Uh there will be few
need adjustment especially close to the
beginning and to the end. Um especially
like if you are correct on inside the
outside may not be correct and those are
not too many of them and we want to make
it correct for the first one because we
need to mirror and then we also need to
uh polar array four times. So you just
want to make sure they are right they
are all touching the stone correctly.
Okay. So once we have that um we are
going to simply creating the surface by
pick up the surface and I simply just
going to use the gumball to extrude it
the surface right here. All right. So
that will cover the prong area and then
you can see we got the solid right
there. Now in some cases uh because the
prong that you have with is with the
angle. So in this case, we might need to
kind of tilt it the prong back a little
bit and make sure that it's not sticking
out. So I'm going to quickly to do
something right there um to address
those certain little tiny prong. They
being stick it out. So I'm going to fast
forward here uh for quickly result.
Maybe I shouldn't tilted the prong like
too much like what I did earlier. So you
guys can try and let me know like which
one work better. Maybe I just need to
have the prong go straight. Um, since
I'm going to extrude the surface
straight. All right. So, once we have
everything, we're just going to coming
into the front view and we're going to
pick up everybody beside this stone and
also those part right there. And I'm
simply just going to mirror to the other
side. So, let's go ahead to use the
mirror command snapping into the zero.
And we want something like this. All
right. Notice that there's something
jamming here. Especially when you see um
the diamond of this one. We need to move
it back. Right. And um if you have a
record history, they may follow all of
them. Just make sure that you need to
cancel the history. All right. Uh you
can have another prong here if you want
to just for the decoration. And the same
thing we're going to do for our prong on
the bottom. Uh right here. You can
actually just using the one prong
instead of like two prong jamming
together and having that prong to moving
into the center, right? Uh that will
work. And just make them slightly bigger
so that will cover all of them. Uh you
can have this one too. Uh just making
them a little bit smaller so you know to
able to filling into the fitting into
the space. Right. Yours may not be
exactly the same like mine because you
know the size of the stone different the
gap of the surface different is actually
play different role here. All right.
Once you have everything I'm just going
to pick up all my curve and just
temporary to hide it. And I'm also going
to group all those things. Right. The
one that I have and I can make it a
little bit closer.
And then I wanted to uh polar array for
again snapping into the zero. And then
you have something like this. And then
you can have two of them get a little
bit higher. So let's go ahead to moving
this one a a bit higher. So you got some
sort of a depth there. And but if you
happen to have something like this where
the stone is hidden hidden there, you
can delete all those stone and using a
prong as an example like what I have
here. Right? So you can arrange the
prong because the prong after they
polish they are nice and shiny and
reflecting the stone or you can change
the middle stone a little bit bigger and
after putting the chain then you will
have a good lucky leaf pendant into your
collection. Stone setting is one of the
very important skill to know as a
jewelry cat designer. Not only you
design a look, you also need to
understand the production process in
order to make sure that your piece can
be cast for stone setting. If you are
really into the jewelry care design,
check out my course for the stone
setting that will definitely level up
your jewelry care design skill. You can
find a link in the description below.
Thank you for watching and I'll see you
next
[Music]